hey everybody big surprise and Inhumans
trailer leaked early so I went ahead and
did a breakdown of it somebody dropped a
trailer early so it's all watermarks so
I have to make this in a funny way but
they'll probably be an official version
sometime really soon
they just finished filming the last
episode in its 8 episodes for the first
season so it's more of a miniseries they
spent way more money to do all the
special effects because it's almost like
doing x-men on TV while doing their
powers so it gets really expensive with
all those special effects so I'll have
to think of a new Marvel giveaway but
just be sure to subscribe to get
everything because they're going to be
rolling out a whole bunch of footage
really soon when it says it's dropping
September 1st that's when it's dropping
at IMAX the actual series premiere is
September 22nd so you get a chance to
see episodes early in a really big
format then everything else is going to
air on TV so even if you don't go to
seat and IMAX you'll still be able to
see all of the episodes on ABC and it's
9:00 p.m. September 22nd but let's just
go to the footage here so you open up
with a shot on the mood just confirming
that at 2:00 LAN will be on the moon in
somebody on earth there's like a
character that's a human that works at a
space agency it seems like she finds out
where it is this sort of serves as a
tipping point for them having to deal
with humans because up until now the
narrative of the trailer is basically
saying that Maximus is tired of hiding
from the humans do we continue to follow
our king and they show you shots of them
all sitting together eating dinner here
everybody but Triton so you have Black
Bolt Medusa Karnak Gorgon crystal and I
guess you could say lock jaws and
sitting here too he pops up later in the
trailer but this is what the interior
looks like it's not quite as
otherworldly as I would expect it looks
a little bit more like a fortress but
you see all the citizens of Atlanta
remember that just because they live in
Atlanta and they have inhuman DNA
doesn't mean they're Inhumans the term
inhuman refers to people of this race
that have gone through the process of
terrigenesis so once you get your powers
you become an inhuman so karnak for
instance is the only member of the royal
family that has not been through
terrigenesis he just a super hardcore
badass who is the chief tactician and
planner so obviously he's team Black
Bolt so when you see him down here on
the ground
here they've been exiled by Maximus in
this big tube but not before you see him
beat the crap out of a bunch of inhuman
guards the way the trailer plays you see
Black Bolt with the royal family
addressing the inhuman people then you
see Maximus looking like he's killing
their ruling council so technically the
Inhumans don't have a ruling Council but
they just seem like members of authority
who have really big say in the
decision-making process so you kill them
you try to imprison the rest of the
royal family to take control
this is crystal here this is them in the
throne room Maximus looks like he's
already on the throne here you can
actually see the black bolt symbol
behind them they're these statues here
are just black bolts ancestors the
previous kings of battle and there was a
comic book recently though that posited
that he had a cousin previously that was
ruler of Atlanta and was banished but
he's called the unspoken I don't think
the TV show is going to do him maybe in
a future season this first season is all
about Maximus taking control in trying
to start a war against the humans and
Black Bolt and the other royal family
trying to stop him but then you see
Medusa on her knees there's a female
voiceover during the trailer we actually
heard it during the teaser trailer it
could be crystal it could be Medusa both
of them are able to talk just fine but
then you see Black Bolt
in the quiet room it looks like he's
being imprisoned here but this is the
only room where he's able to speak where
he won't shatter everything around him
you see lockjaw teleport him to earth
you may have seen this footage before if
somebody posted it to Twitter a month
ago or so but it looks like he helps
Black Bolt escape to earth so they don't
get swept up in Maximus as COO but you
see like all these cars swerve around
this was all filmed in Hawaii so I don't
know if this is going to double for
another city I'm assuming it's just
going to be Hawaii because later you
finally see Tritan
dive into the ocean you actually get a
better look at him here this is what he
looks like they'll probably more special
effects when they post the official
trailer but then you see Black Bolt
running through the city
you see Gorgon use his stop ability on
one of them he actually has like giant
hooves I don't know how they dealt with
that from a CG standpoint he might not
have hooves on the TV show but we'll
find out whenever they post that final
trailer and then you see this big action
set piece play out where black bolts
captured by human police officers and
you see him flip a car with his ability
so because everything isn't blowing up
I'm guessing this is an unfinished
version of the trailer they'll just be
more special effects so because they
just finished filming and because
they're going to be bringing a whole
bunch of stuff to Comic Con next month
my guess is is that they'll drop an
official trailer really soon and then
they'll drop more footage from the first
episode of Comic Con
when we get to August within about four
weeks that's when they'll really start
pumping stuff out so if you wonder why
they've been so quiet about it recently
just because they've still been filming
the show but all the episodes will air
this year then like I said next year
whenever everything comes back agents of
shield will just take that Friday night
timeslot so of course all the videos I
do for it will be posting on Friday
night so everybody might take a little
while to get used to that but I'll just
remind people you'll see footage
dropping Friday night so you'll be like
oh okay this is happening now usually
the best way for me to tell people when
something is happening is just to post a
video for it so you see it in your feed
but as long as you have those alerts
enabled you'll see the videos so it'll
be no problem it just generally the
story of the first season like I said is
them trying to stop Maximus from
starting an all-out war with the
Inhumans in the earth they haven't said
exactly how they're going to deal with
agents of shield but because agents of
shield season 5 is moving to space look
you see Coulson and outerspace here
the window closes in less than two
minutes
take them
[Music]
all right so I say to you that one
it seems like they're doing agents of
sword and it'll be more of a galactic
thing now they did tease multiverse but
I feel like the bigger teaser from that
last episode of season four with them
just teasing bigger Galactic conflict I
think that's mostly in the name of
ratcheting up the WTF like making things
even crazier because it's like if this
is going to be our last season and they
haven't confirmed that yet it could be
the last season they want to go out with
a bang and because they just did all
this Doctor Strange stuff this year they
feel a little bit freer to do weirder
magic based stuff so Ghost Rider will
come back in some form and I do think
that the bargain that Coulson made with
the rider to become the Coulson Rider
was that he would take the mantle
eventually so at some future later date
he will become the next Ghost Rider
after Robbie Reyes stops being him but
he's a young person so it doesn't look
like he's going to stop being Ghost
Rider any time soon because everybody
liked him so much so they haven't said
exactly when shield is going to premiere
but it'll be sometime in like February
March April
then it'll air all of its episodes
without any big breaks maybe like one or
two breaks because it'll be a 22-episode
season but let me know what you guys
think about all this I mean if Inhumans
is even halfway good I think it'll be
fun there's not a whole lot that's
happening Friday night so even if people
wait to watch on their DVRs till
Saturday morning I feel like the show
will be fine so really big Network shows
like this depend on advertisers so the
best thing you can do is just watch the
show it's only eight episode so it's
actually a relatively low time
investment so depending on the
characters the storylines the things
they do in episodes I'll do Easter Egg
videos for that believe all your video
requests in the comments below but what
will happen next is I have new flash
there's also spider-man that drop
there's a whole bunch of III stuff
that's happening but Tom Holland confirm
is they are planning a trilogy with his
character but the second two movies
won't be called homecoming it'll be you
know spider-man homecoming then
spider-man two spider-man 3
they just haven't decided what the
titles of those going to be yet so
Inhumans Civil War right or die what you
guys wait for everything to post you can
click here for new black panther and you
can click here for brand new Game of
Thrones
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you